thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a dark wild
ride with Stevo we've got dark humor
Galore it's Sam Morrell and man do I
love this guy he was in The Joker movie
with Joaquin Phoenix he's got crazy
stuff to tell us about that he really
gets too dark sometimes and he's gonna
tell us exactly what that's all about
plus it doesn't get a lot darker than
the story about me with that man's wife
telling you this one really is uh a
little bit shadier than normal so
without further Ado let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen Sam Morrell thanks
for having me yeah did they say that
right you [__] nailed it no one ever
gets it right and I don't like to
correct people what does it say Moral
Moral yeah she looks moral but it's yeah
it's not you know look at these dates
yeah I'm on the road hard dude I you're
playing Madison Square Gardens all by
yourself theater yeah it's there's well
there's the MSG which is like I don't
know like 18 000 people that's where
like Bill Burrs playing I'm playing the
theater which is like 53 or 5400 I think
well that's still pretty still pretty
cool yeah a lot of people it's a lot of
people I'm a native New Yorker so that's
pretty damn cool yeah is that the
biggest venue you've done oh yeah I mean
I used to open for like you know Comics
so I'd open in bigger shows but the
bigger shows that it's the biggest show
I've done for my show yeah great yeah
it's [__] cool man this is this is
quite the setup man yeah thanks man we
love it we've been uh
doing it for for a minute now it's been
uh 160 something weeks well no we're on
we're deep in 170s but whatever well New
York no one is just without stuff on
their feet right because of red like
this is a very la like you don't just
walk around without he's comfortable
with you yeah I'll take it yeah you
don't have an odor I mean that's it's
nice and you have an odor you don't see
many people walking around New York but
I used to have a roommate and she had
the worst smelling feet ever she uh she
would go like kayaking in the Hudson
River with these shoes on and then just
like walk around the shoes and I'd be
like you smell bad yeah and then she'd
get offended by like well if I don't say
it like I just I mean we're in like a
one bedroom together would divide it up
it's a tiny place if you don't say
something you're [__] you just smell
[__] all day but then if you say
something you're an [__] it's a
predicament yeah well that's good that
you notice is he doesn't smell no yeah
that's good so watch that same time
tomorrow your Netflix comedy special I
watched last night dude I don't normally
hey I don't really watch a lot of comedy
specials B when I do I don't like laugh
a lot and uh my girl was like wow this
really has you laughing out loud oh my
God a lot I I I super enjoyed it man so
this that came out last year yeah that
was last year I'll try to tape another
one in like March but uh wow that's a
quick turnaround I for me it's slow
actually because I you just have so much
desperation as a comic just at first
just being like I need people to come to
the shows I need people to come to the
shows and now they're finally come in I
can be like I can take a breath but no
dude I did a rooftop one during the
pandemic I was doing a special on random
rooftops because I'm like people are
going to forget about me I'm I'm nervous
I'm losing steam here so yeah brutal
that sounds like uh like trades of
alcoholism yeah maybe
expand on that well I'm just saying like
uh you know like we're we're all like
you know addicts and alcoholics in here
like uh all sober nerds and I think that
there's just like this this uh built-in
discomfort this anxiety this feeling
everything's not gonna be okay like I'm
not okay like I gotta I gotta hurry I
gotta I gotta try and do something so
I'll be okay yeah I think oh and also
understand it but just can go away so
easily I've just watched so many good
Comics just kind of take their foot off
the gas and you just you can lose it you
can lose
being funny you can lose the the
audience there's so many things you can
lose so I've been so you know nervous
about it and then with I did a special
two ago that was on YouTube and that
really helped people come out to shows
it's like over 12 million views on
YouTube now so that like just putting
out for free I had big Comics being like
don't put out a [__] special for free
you're an idiot Like Comics I really
respect and uh I was like hey I'm gonna
do it I mean what else am I gonna do
you're done with the material yeah
people won't buy it you put it out so
then I did that that came out February
2020 so you put out a free special with
the hopes to tour that was like right
when I started yeah so everything shut
down
uh yeah I didn't so that's why I did
another rooftop one so it was it was
just straight fear it was like I'm gonna
lose everyone who I just got which I
probably wasn't but that's the Panic
yeah yeah so finally you can take a deep
breath and you know
and I am a little hungover to answer
your question sure it is it is traits of
alcoholism too when you were performing
on the the rooftops in New York that was
during covet right oh yeah and it's just
deep mental illness I mean you're going
where pigeons go to get your self-esteem
yeah you're deeply dark were people
actually coming to watch your set yeah
how many people showed up yeah like 30
or 40 a show but that's great I mean
what happened was you getting I was
doing other people's shows you're
literally doing a show in like the East
River Amphitheater you know with like a
hobo pissing and you're 20 feet from
them like you're like holy [__] talk
about like New York everyone in it
together you're really in it together so
uh you know you bomb you do 10 like
every comic stage time so valuable
during this pandemic so every comic is
just like oh [__] we gotta I gotta get
in the show so you're like [__] you're
doing eight minutes not ten and then I
was like [__] this dude I'm doing my own
so I just started posting on Instagram
like if you got a roof a mic an amp and
alcohol I'll come to your I'll come to
your roof and you know you're climbing
fire escapes and people were just up
there and I was like this is [__]
cool so I do an hour let's go to work on
stuff
yeah people were everybody was wearing
masks there that's the funny thing is
like I remember putting out this thing
being like I'm gonna get like canceled
if I post a video of like people
Outdoors not wearing masks people on
Twitter were like trying to ruin your
life they're like he's a super spreader
and at the time he's like we don't know
[__] you know so so I was like [__]
cheating some angles of people I just
told I doing one show I was like Hey can
everyone just put a mask on for the next
like few jokes and everyone put them on
that's great and I was like just [__]
that's that's every laugh or the special
just yeah that in it's weird now like I
go to the grocery market and you see
like one or two people with masks and
you're like what the [__] are you doing
wearing a mask yeah you know do whatever
you want to do but for me I was more
nervous because it was people during
covid were uh
there were people on Twitter and stuff
being like shame on you for touring
during a time like this I'm like people
have families you [__] lunatic yeah
like people need to work yeah did you
have your podcast at the time going no
we didn't really do what start that's
actually kind of what started the
podcast because the premise of our
podcast it's called we might be drunk
Stevo you've been on it yeah Daddy loved
it we uh it's that Gotham podcast right
yeah we love doing it but it started
because the prep it was originally
called one more drink because the idea
was like you know Mark and I were open
mikers together and we would you know
every at first you're open mic because
you're drunk every night and then you
start doing the road and you don't get
to see each other as much so you have
that one night where you're like one
more drink dude it turns into 6 a.m
you're like what the [__] did we just do
to ourselves it's Tuesday we're psychos
this is our free night so then it's like
turned into the spirit of one more drink
we'll keep drinking and holy [__] it is
hard to keep up a drinking Pockets
because like I love drinking but then
sometimes it's like it's like oh we can
only record Tuesday at noon you're like
all right
I mean I guess it's technically we might
be drunk but these times like yeah we
should probably drink for sure yeah I
like that man
um the pandemic was so gnarly dude and
uh
outdoor shows started cropping up in L.A
there was uh there was one that I did
quite regularly I forget even what it
was called but uh it was they just
turned like a parking lot into oh that
was Matt Rife show the little the little
uh pickup truck right was that the Magic
Castle no it was uh like off Hollywood
Boulevard if I forget what oh I did that
one too yeah it was it was in the round
it was pretty pretty cool I remember
that yeah it was pretty cool but then
the second you go indoors you're like oh
my it's like [__] with a condom
versus without if you haven't had sex in
two years you're like man condoms are
great yeah yeah but then once you take
it off you're like oh that's that was a
[__] ruse whatever that was but yeah
we did the out but then La there weren't
that many shows because I was in LA at
the beginning of the pandemic and then
went to New York l.a's got all this
outdoor space there weren't that many
shows you go to New York they're like
dude I got a show on 49th and 7th and
you're like on the street they're in the
corner everywhere there's a show people
like the people that we used to make fun
of on the subway who were like can
everyone uh I'd like your attention
that's what we turned into so you know
like buskers basically everything turned
into a [__] uh what do you call them
like not uh like what Dave Dave
Chappelle was doing he was like 16 17
just doing stand up on the street yeah
that's pretty cool pretty cool I
remember like my whole thing like you
know I had
I had this joke that I really enjoyed
and I was kind of scared to say it but I
was like hey you know like this pandemic
shirts it's really upsetting to see that
um you know thousands of people are
dying every day but I'm just a like
Curious guy I couldn't help but Wonder
like how many people die anyway right so
I Googled it I Googled it and uh you
know the last like reliable statistics
they had said that uh approximately 7
500 Americans die on average every
single day
that's how it shocked me what shocked me
was how many Americans are born every
single day
eleven thousand which begs the question
should the coronavirus not pick up the
pace
and yeah that would I enjoyed that joke
and when I went out I don't think the
Chinese are onto something
right and and uh and it got a laugh and
it was like oh wow dude that's like my
like I'm very light on topical humor I
love topical jokes
I love I love a good topical joke you
know it's like it's because you just
there's something great about burning a
joke and being like that's that you know
I miss like monologues late night
monologues you know I love that the
spirit of those types of jokes we were
like oh the the Gilgo Beach murders and
the news like something like that but uh
you just burn it and that's the and it's
you don't have to worry about honing a
joke for another special you just
[__] throw it into the world and you
get points for you know the shelf life
of it you're like oh this this is right
yeah is that you you interned or you
worked for yeah that was a long time ago
yeah a little bear yeah
ah Stephen Colbert he's hilarious and a
master of the English language but if
I'm not mistaken he's only mastered one
language and I think that is a little
bit weak let me tell you soy una
professional which means I am a
professional idiot and I said it in
Spanish how because I'm learning Spanish
with Babel this is the best way to learn
a language these days if you spend 15
hours on this app and by the way the app
is like a fun video game which makes
learning Spanish or any other language
totally enjoyable in 15 hours equates to
uh taking a university course a full
course in learning that language you
could be speaking a whole new language
in as little as three weeks baby with
Babel and you know what the listeners of
the Wild Ride podcast they get
55 off their subscription that's you
baby you want to stop being a loser and
learn more than one language then it's
Babble time baby and to get 55 off you
go to babble.com Stevo that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash Stevo enjoy 55 off
your
subscription now let's get back to it
yeah on the daily the cold Baron comedy
Center yeah so you were that was your
job coming up with jokes or would you no
we were like [__] no I didn't come up
with I wish
I pissed him a joke they'd [__] fire
me in a second no I was like yeah coffee
runs like picking up Steven is falafel
uh you know it's BLT with one full
tomato I still remember the order
BLT with one full tomato I'm like all
right I mean are they skimping on tomato
what's the [__] story here Steven but
no he was a cool boss he was he was very
nice to everybody and that show was was
legendary you know yeah big time of
course big time remember when we uh we
were in New York we went to The Colbert
Show we've and like
with the nobody set it up nothing like
that we were just like oh let's go to
the queen because they had a line down
the [__] yes whatever so
uh that we were unannounced we just
showed up at the Colbert and I'm like
maybe maybe they'll be stroked I'm here
I don't know should we go like right to
the front of the line I'm like I'm here
and they're like oh cool so they let us
in like just as like The Green Room just
has like regular old Spectators yeah and
and the second that we were unsupervised
we just like barged down into the guts
of the place we're just chilling there
like Stephen Colbert walks by and I'm
like yeah what's up dude yeah we have
footage of that yeah we were so not
supposed to be there at all that's
amazing yeah yeah I remember you had the
the camera famous people should be
assassins
yeah you're just like oh Stevo's not
gonna shoot the president
yeah he was like Hey Stevo huge fan yeah
yeah cool thanks oh my God it's Stephen
Colbert right and uh and we didn't make
a big deal out of it he he was super
cool are you guys rolling that like
Viacom family right yeah you know what's
yeah what's
[Music]
dude they [__] that's a that's a big
sinking ship right there Nickelodeon no
everything the whole thing that was
[__] like Netflix kind of yeah but
that was everything think about
Paramount and cables around yeah now
it's all just I mean it's all just
streaming now it's Paramount plus yeah I
think viacom's in better shape than uh
what is it Time Warner Discovery yeah I
get AOL that's that's HBO Max
uh Time Warner
um
like it says it's all that yeah I mean
dude it's crazy though pretty soon
they're just gonna start buying out all
these things it's gonna be like three
main companies at the end of it well
you gotta Wonder like everything feels
like it's going to turn into one big
company because like they gobble up this
and that and it's all but the world
changes a little bit and these big huge
things are failing well Netflix couldn't
afford like to keep to sustain this
business model that seems why that's
part of the strike right I mean fifteen
dollars for all this [__] like I said
some of the money they were throwing
around I'm like yeah you can't just
[__] do you look up who they pay some
some [__] you've never even heard of
they dropped like 900 mil on and you're
like yeah I've never even heard of that
[__] yeah somebody said that was a part
of their like strategy was buying out
all these like specials and so they
they're losing money on a yearly basis
but they're also like gaining the net
worth and you know because they own
these assets so then the play would be
to sell out later yeah but I don't know
how I mean there's stock in the last
three months is just [__] through the
roof yeah they're not paying Riders what
is it yeah
yeah I I don't know we're all gonna get
replaced by AI man I I this self-driving
car [__] like uh uh I mean
literally we're in a car this could be
yeah whoever drove here is [__]
finished
that's it no San Francisco they have
like the sensor driving car that's like
how dystopian this future is they just
have the cars driving through San
Francisco the the people are on the
street the cars are driven by no one
yeah the people who have squeegees
they're [__] probably get money
there's no one in the car are they
actually like yeah they're starting to
do they roll that out but like here have
you I don't know New York but like
you're the end of like if you order a
Postmates in West Hollywood they have a
little robot that comes your thing you
put it in and just you see it riding on
the street I've seen those yeah but how
long do you think that could last though
because I've seen it but people are
interested
destroying them stealing the food like
really yeah
The Dominoes like two years ago they
rolled out a selfless delivery driver
the the they come
they'll come to your like the front what
you don't believe that no no I'm just
laughing because I [__] ads and
Isaac's bringing up YouTube videos with
ads on it
does Steve not pay you enough
that's why people complain that there's
ads on the podcast is because they have
this type of situation to where they
have to [__] log into the podcast and
then they have to watch [__] local
ads and then ads on top of it it's like
right okay
um
no but so so anyway yeah like Domino's
Pizza is doing the self-driving and they
pull up to your curb the only problem
that AI has
that they're trying to solve is from the
door from the car to your door like the
robot can't make it upstairs but there's
that company that's like making it so
that they can walk upstairs so once they
like nail that once they can get a
slinky crack this code
by the way the other thing I heard about
is like these cars they drive so
cautiously because it's not a per
they're going by sensors so a person
maybe could like fill in a gap so it's
like the robots they drive like
Canadians basically they're like slow
they kind of you know well Elon Musk was
saying so there's like 44 000 deaths a
year from like vehicles in America in
America right so he's like
if if I can get that number down to four
thousand he's like what the people are
going to do is they're still going to
complain because oh my God you see that
self-driving car it got in a crash but
he's like we just got that number from
40 000 down to four thousand so there's
still some problems with it but I think
like yeah well
there's definitely some problems with
that thinking because
on a case-by-case basis if you can
actually assign
blame for a death to someone
that person's in trouble
like and if he's the guy that you can
assign the blame to because he's
responsible for the self-driving
situation that he stands to be in a lot
of trouble so even if they get that
number down significantly sure yes in a
big picture but it it it's kind of like
uh you can there's three people in the
boat you know like only like two people
can survive like you gotta throw
somebody out like yeah he's through you
know you save two lives but you also
killed somebody I wonder if the Japanese
uh self-driving cars are going to be
worse drivers yeah or an email yeah yeah
get the voice but I can't drive I'm I
have a license but I'm like I should I
shouldn't have a license that's I'm a
New Yorker you just we don't drive I
grew up in London England and I never
even learned how to drive until I turned
20 years old oh wow and then I got my
first DUI within six months I got my
second DUI within one month of getting
my license back from my first DUI well
this is like the case for the
self-driving cars they're not getting
drunk right one time I was getting blown
in a car like in the taxi cab in New
York and the driver and the driver said
you know a person's driving this car and
that's the first time I thought like
[__] self-driving dude robots yeah
robot cars I met yeah that's because
everybody takes taxis in New York so I'm
sure yeah taxicab confessions in New
York was a good thing they've seen but
oh but that now but right now we're
losing the cabs to the Uber that's what
you'll get is like Ubers and lists so I
try not to take those but then like
you'll tell that you're a black friend
they're like [__] Yellow Cabs you're
like all right they're not perfect you
know you have to Dabble
um
how did you respond to the taxi driver
saying that that someone was driving the
car I was like oh sorry I don't know
what to say
and then she stopped and we just went
into my apartment how long ago was this
it was years I was very young you know
but uh yeah no it's not like a it's not
like a proud story you know six months
ago I mean it's kind of proud it's
pretty cool but it's not a proud story
like uh the all boys school stories yeah
I loved that though oh yeah I went to
the all boys school yeah we would uh
that was basically that's a real story
my friend died we used to all jack off
together and uh I did lose a good part
of that joke because it was like two it
was making people too sad but yeah we
used to all there were four of us we
would watch we were like seventh grade
so like by the way this is another bit
that if I do in a black crowd they're
just like what the [__] are you talking
about man I was like we all used to jack
off together and they're like no we did
not I'm like oh sorry you know but yeah
we used to uh we would like yeah these
would mean white kids and we would
masturbate and uh in the same room but
we know we can we guarded our Corner
yeah as I said we kept it civilized but
we you know we're watching porn they
used uh pillows yeah kind of like the
wall at the urinal yeah I remember a
gentleman's club that was how and we uh
we jack off to porn and we and look we
were kids so we didn't last long it's
like we're like oh my God titties you
just come which was like making little
games out of me like oh I came first
yeah it was like okay cookie well I
think that was part of it is uh the guy
I said uh
there's something about how I think I
cut something about how we like came in
order like he died he came first and
then he was also the first to die and I
was like [__] I hope we don't die in
that order
but uh but yeah he was a heroin addict
so he passed away but uh
yeah no we we would uh I mean it's such
a weird thing you know all boys school
we would just uh that was kind of what
you we didn't really know girls yet so
you end up meeting girls in the area but
uh yeah we uh that was after school we
get baked and do that [__] and the weed
and the jacking off together is a bad
combo because while you're jacking off
you're like is this weird that I'm
jacking off your children and then
you're like no that's just the weed
yeah I mean but like being being a young
kid with all that testosterone like I
remember I'd have buddies over in eighth
grade and like might we'd be on the
trampoline my one better be like I'm
just gonna go jack off in your bathroom
real quick and you're like dude like
he's all happy yeah that's you stop
saying that as an adult yeah as an adult
you just you just do this
you just say I need to use the bathroom
yeah and that's it I need to take a
number three I love that
um that you
tell us here that you had a line where I
cut jokes because because your your
humor it leans dark you know what else
leans a little dark my facial hair and
I'm not having it that's why I cut it
with Harry's Razors man these are good
I've been using them for years long
before they ever became sponsors of the
Wild Ride podcast why because they're
the best razors you can get man as good
as any razors in the world anyway and no
gimmicks man doesn't need to light up or
vibrate or any of this stupid stuff
people charge you way too much money for
now just top quality products and this
craft handle I'm telling you it's
something else now you can get the craft
starter kit it's a 17 value you got the
weighted ergonomic handle the five blade
razor the travel cover for the for the
blades and the foaming shaved gel that
Seventeen dollar value yours for just 10
bucks yeah that's if you go to
harrys.com Stevo that's h a r r y s.com
slash Stevo the craft starter kit baby
and jump on that because it's epic
harrys.com Stevo now let's get back to
it
well yeah you got to figure out where
the line is and like I always said about
stand up it's like one of the only
things like you don't really focus Test
movies right you kind of like scorsese's
not like take this [__] to Kansas let's
see what they think he's just like this
is the movie but with stand up you'd go
on the road you see what is working
what's not working and and it should
work everywhere in my mind so uh
yeah that was one part where I had a
joke about speaking at the funeral and
uh like making jokes about it like it's
what he would have wanted it was too
much for people they were like this is
too dark but uh yeah I mean of course we
made jokes about it you know it's like
you make you make jokes about everything
I think you actually left that in this
special
some parts I definitely cut I I don't
even remember what I kept in no but he
uh you know he really he really would
have found it I wouldn't do jokes about
that like you know your your friends are
the ones that laugh at Your Darkest [__]
they're friends so he would have found
this so funny so uh yeah I mean it's
almost like a little homage to to your
buddy who lost so it was a fun thing to
throw in there but uh yeah and all my
friends who I grew up with were like I
[__] love that I know who that is and
I love that that was in there and uh of
course those are the jokes your mom's
like I should have like bailed 10
minutes early you know I used to have a
bit about is a true story about how uh
I met this I met this girl like years
ago on an app and she was like super hot
and I remember we like kissed on a first
date and I kissed her and then I like uh
it was like a cold New York winter she
was so proper she was like oh my I
didn't expect that and I just whatever
never heard from her again and then uh
three months later on like a Friday
afternoon she just text me where are you
I'm at lunch with my parents you know
and she I was like I'm at lunch with my
phone she goes I want to see you and I
want to get freaky with you which I'm
like I don't know what the [__] this
means so it's like okay uh yeah I was
like oh yeah which I don't know how to
respond to a text like that and she
writes do you want to get your dick
sucked or not and I'm like a kid so I'm
like [__] yeah so I you know in the in
the bid I'm like so I reveal that I'm
with my parents so I excuse myself from
lunch with my parents took the phone
call and the line that's like the
biggest laugh is like I lied to my mom
and I was like I gotta get out of here
this audition just came up and my mom
goes go get him Sammy and I was like Ugh
you know disgusting yeah like my mom's
cheering on my quest for a [__] and
it's like a long story but the what
really what happens in real life and and
in a bit is she's going down to me at
her place and a dude just comes out and
is like they were expecting me to be
cool with this but he's just like are we
gonna do this and I was like are you
[__] crazy so like this is like a
long bit and my mom I see her face in
the crowd and I just see her do this
and I'm just like oh God you couldn't
have said her like four rows further so
I'd have to see that [__] yeah now I
like hate myself but I'm like what am I
gonna do change my ACT it's my ACT I was
working I was building I was taping a
special and my mom was in the crowd she
wanted to be supportive but you know but
when she asked you to come to the show
where you're like [__] I just always
tell her there might be stuff that you
don't love what I always say is like
who's the garden is the greatest
comedian ever and she'll say Richard
Pryor and I'm like do you think his mom
was cool with all his [__] I'm sure she
was like what do you think private mom
was like could you lose the free basing
chunk and he's like that's the best
[__] chunk you know right yeah that
was the most uncomfortable I saw you at
a show when your family came and we knew
the bit was coming and you because it's
not for them well it's a bonus if they
like it but you can't write jokes you're
like you know who'll find this funny mom
you can't do that his bit in particular
was him busting a nut out of an airplane
and so like we so he came back I just
remember you're just like giggling like
the difference when I'm talking about
jacking off like my my Show's multimedia
so like I tell a story and then I show
it happening so like
so his sister's there his dad his dad's
wife is like their kids
[__] row right it's a little
different yeah you can't really just
like block that one out huh yeah a
picture's a thousand words that's the
thing is like you know I did a show like
a year ago at the Beacon Theater in New
York at the time was the biggest show
I'd ever done it was a big deal my mom's
there and my therapist is sitting right
behind her and which by the way Freud
would [__] have a field day with this
[__] I'm asking him I'm like did she
hate this joke I told he goes I didn't
see her laugh and I was like man he's
like my spy this is so crazy but you
know not all the jokes are for them
right I've always told my dad my family
not to base their opinion of the show on
the material rather on the audience
reaction to the material I said if the
crowd is laughing then that's all you
need to worry I feel like Hitler said
that to his parents too
they're loving her so you should really
you should really try to give it
everybody's with me here no you know uh
it is hard because I have certain bits I
remember uh I I was in a bar in Vermont
and a dude just [__] attacked me he
was a crazy guy and what'd you say to
piss him off he was in a blackout and he
walks over to me and he goes uh
he goes University of Vermont I'm with
three other comedians you know and I
said uh no and he goes master's degree
and I said you're getting colder just
being silly and he goes uh I'm gonna
beat the [__] out of you and I was like
what and he go I was just kind of like
[__] up ignoring him and he goes he
goes he goes no he goes I'm gonna beat
the [__] out of all of you is what he
said but he's only looking at me so I
was kind of like all right whatever
ignore him as I turn around he takes a
pint glass and smashes it over my head
and I just turn around like what the
[__] and we all kind of stand up and
then he runs and the cops got him and he
went for the cops gun but you know yeah
they didn't like that they well if
you're white you get to live apparently
and uh turns out he was a therapist and
whatever so this whole crazy story
happens and my mom is like so upset by
and I was like well Mom here's what
happened I got attacked and my instinct
was how can I win in the end and I win
in the end by making it a bit in a
special like that's that is us taking
control of bad [__] in our life same
with the story
of the guy walking in by the way if I
did that to a woman my [__] career
would be over if I brought a woman home
and I was just like hey I got another
guy in the closet right here yeah that's
[__] my friend that's career ending yeah
but so I mean like yeah that's a little
that will traumatize you a little bit
turned into a bit now I'm happy I win
it's like you you get laughs in that
story
really it's you taking the power back in
the story so uh that's that's how I try
to explain it to her is this is me
winning in the end even if I'm the butt
of the joke I still get to win did you
ever hear that comedian on the podcast
talk about his buddy he's like I'm not
gonna say who but he's like you know I
this chick took me home she was too
[__] up he's like she was tying me up
to you know that's what she was into she
tied me up and I'm sitting there tied up
and she passes out
and then her dad walks in the door and
then and then he was like oh [__] like
her dad's home and her dad comes naked
yeah butt naked okay her dad walks in
and he pulls down his pants and starts
sucking his dick
shut the [__] up wait that's not a real
story
what I thought you said he was thinking
a totally different direction than I
thought yeah he was probably getting
there or whatever naked or not the story
is the dad robbed it doesn't check out
yeah you busted or not damn that's a
that's a dark [__] night I mean you
definitely got a case I think
I remember can you imagine taking him to
court I think it just keeps going he
[__] blew me to relive the moment
yeah and she's the accomplice what does
she I mean yeah what do you say if your
dad does that that's a weird
relationship it's a weird thing yeah
starting to throw a wrench in this
conversation but yeah it was like what
the [__] there's a particularly fun
story where we were filming Wild Boys in
Thailand and and I I uh with this um
met this lady at the bar and she's
coming back to my house with drink
s'mores okay and and um
the uh there's me and a producer guy
would go back and then so the next thing
you know
uh the producer guy is is getting head
in this this lady's bedroom and her
husband walks into the room
and uh
the producer guy says get the [__] out
of here and the husband says
it it it's cool I'll just watch and the
producer guy says it's not [__] cool
get the [__] out of here he kicks him
out of him out of his own bedroom and
then you know who's the bad guy in this
thing that's a tough one and uh and and
then uh were you there yeah I was there
oh my God I witnessed the whole thing
the producer guy kind of got frustrated
with the situation he left but I stayed
I hung out and uh
the guy gave me a condom and uh I humped
his wife in front of him oh my God
Stephen
that is crazy yeah it happened and and
now I'm
now taking the power back
here's an idea
why just take power back when you can
take power that you never even had in
the first place see what I'm talking
about if you can build an audience
online then why aren't you selling stuff
to that audience it's called ship
station baby this is how I sell
everything online on Amazon that's where
we sell the most Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole but how do we get it there
ship station baby how do we get our
products out to our customers ship
station baby and if you go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
Stevo then you get a two-month risk-free
totally free trial and why is it special
because look when I get an order no
matter where I get it from
a label gets printed out my guys in the
warehouse they grab the label they put
the item in the Box slap the label on
the box and it's out the door and ship
station makes that so easy plus it
incorporates all the different ways to
ship things I'm talking FedEx UPS United
States Postal Service and on top of that
they hook you up with the best rates
that you can get from all of those
Services I'm telling you it all comes
into one simple interface no matter how
you sell stuff it makes it so easy that
it is a crime to have an audience and
not be selling to them so go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
Stevo for your 60-day no hassle totally
free risk free trial you're not gonna
believe it man and hurry up and do it
and time to take advantage of the
holidays shipstation.com with the promo
code Stevo now let's ride this baby out
sounds like you're just [__] a guy's
life
yeah okay so it's a win-win
wow I'm winning again there's this comic
as a joke uh his name is Dwight York his
joke I love what goes my wife said the
best sex we ever had is when I snuck him
through the window wearing a ski mask I
have no idea what she's talking about
it's a great [__] joke good one
who'd you just pull up here
no it's not him that's a football player
that's a guy who'd kick your ass no it's
yeah he's like a bald guy with a with
long hair
um so growing up in New York City there
he is yeah oh that guy yeah
the growing up in New York City what's
the craziest Subway story that you have
I have so many a true story
um I used to have a bit about this too
but a true story a guy I was on a train
with a girl was dating once and a guy
started jacking off to her on the train
I mean she was hot but still it's a
crazy uh I mean even I waited till we
got home you know but uh he's just
rubbing one out to her and I'm like what
the hell and she was kind of like one of
those so she like pushed me to say
something she's like well you said you
need to say something I'm like what do
you want me to [__] say to this guy
he's clearly insane so I was like hey
man you got to cut it out and and he
said I was doing it to you
and in the joke I walk back to her and I
go you're not gonna say something you
know that's good I flip it on her but
yeah no that was a weird one
um the guy's rubbing one out in the
train was I mean that was such a
constant it's like yeah I mean that's
your home happens a lot yeah we're in
your home right now so you get to jack
off I guess
um
that was a bad one I mean not we we
weren't that bad kids but uh
yeah I mean I saw a crazy one was a
person jumped out of a building once and
landed like 10 feet in front of me that
was a [__] bad one yeah I was walking
to the bus and uh Jesus and a lady took
her life by jumping out of a building
and splat if I didn't take my metro card
out I'm [__] dead so that was crazy
if I didn't stop you stopped to take it
out yeah I stopped I was like oh I'm
gonna find I was like hold on I gotta
get my metro card out and splat wow
oh without a question how old were you
sixth grade I wouldn't have I got me out
of a history test the next day that I
did not study for but it was I remember
uh calling a friend about yeah well she
hits the ground Splat and then doesn't
die instantly which I remember being
like when that happens it's like you
feel like you're like your mind does
[__] to protect you we were like did I
Stumble onto a movie set or something
like clearly this isn't real so but then
I see people are freaked out and my
friend's mom was with him and she they
were behind me they're like 20 steps
behind me and she like it's like is
everyone okay and then someone runs into
a store to get her a blanket which I'm
like because she said I'm cold those
were her last words I'm cold oh she was
still able to talk so able to talk but
like on her face like it was like [__]
up she went face down Splat and I guess
very they made out I don't even know if
she was able to say it you know yeah
well but she said I'm cold and they
Someone caught that blanket and died and
I remember I called my I called my
friend I had a good friend to it and his
mom was just [__] batshit insane so I
remember I called him to like tell him
what happened I just needed a telephone
my parents weren't home you know they
were working and I and I called him and
he uh
his mom picked up the phone he wasn't
home and she was like she just was one
of those people that would talk about
herself for like 20 minutes to a kid it
was like inappropriate it was like she
was talking so she's like 20 minutes and
then I did this and then this happened
and then I was like uh-huh she's like
how was your day I was like I just saw
someone die and she was like well
Elliot's not home right now I was like
what a [__] weird convo and uh yeah
and my school they were really nice they
all called to check on us and uh but
yeah it's crazy [__] to see yeah is it
weird that I'm dying to know how high
she jumped from my guess would I don't
didn't see but it wasn't that tall a
building that's probably why she didn't
die instantly I knew a kid who died that
way too commit suicide yeah uh but I
mean I was then angry you angry for a
sec because you're like you could have
[__] killed be an adult and kill
yourself with pills or something you
know or like be like Samsung and have
suicide Nets around your building at
least that would be [__] cool I think
uh pretty recently somebody in New York
just jumped off a really high building
sure it happens like daily body hit
something and cut in half on the way oh
I saw that on TMZ yeah it's pretty
gnarly that's like that's like the way
people die in like comedies you know
like they kill the villain where they
like they fall through a spike or
something yeah or like [__] the end
of the South Park movie you know he just
throws the guy through the Saddam he
throws into the spike I mean have you
got have you seen anybody die like in
front of your face I've never either is
that the only time no is another time uh
that's like the difference between like
New York and here yeah there's just so
many people as you said it's like people
are gonna a new person was born after
that so you know three more uh yeah
watching people dies
oh wow yeah it was like super heavy and
then I have to go and like call their
parents and like wow when they die in
their in your arms like they're like
having an overdose they're like
convulsing and you're like um no it's
it's like after and it's there's no
convulsing but it's I get to the like
right after they die and I'm trying to
like hit him with Narcan and stuff like
that and this has happened not even in
the sober living when I was using two oh
wow just die right do they poop when
you're holding them no no no no that's a
myth no I I mean I don't know I didn't
smell anything or I didn't feel it
um yeah Vinnie I guess you're not
supposed that's not the thing you're
supposed to do first someone dies
it's official everybody yeah I've been
eating Vinnie was a prolific uh IV
heroin user oh wow he lived in Skid Row
around here wow you're very overweight
for a heroin addict that's crazy I know
well I gained a lot of weight during
sobriety oh good yeah good that's good
lived in a porta potty oh wow it was it
was um a handicap it's a wheelchair
accessible Port body so it was more
luxurious oh nice for fun he would just
shoot up water because he likes shooting
up so much did you really yeah damn yeah
I loved it everything everything about
the lifestyle so you put you still would
do that now or no no no no no no no damn
needle LSD right yeah anything that you
could put in a needle do you ever put in
your dick like in Trainspotting where's
the craziest place you ever shut up my
feet yeah because of the vein there yeah
well well the veins are like super small
on your feet but I just shot out all my
veins at a point where I just like wow
they're just all scars so I just
couldn't hit anymore and I'm not gonna
like snort heroin because [__] [__] so
it's like is that why you have sleeves I
heard like people like have like I mean
not everybody but like tattoo sleeves
but like where they you know they'd have
tits and they'd shoot up right between
the tits where the veins are so I didn't
have I didn't have sleeves when I was
getting loaded all my tattoos are in
sobriety because you why would you waste
money on tattoos
exactly yeah right
um man that that's uh that's fascinating
stuff man who's the other person you saw
die
um it was just a random person like like
the zip up in the on the street it
wasn't as dramatic and then I knew a kid
it's the reason I never did Co because I
knew a kid who uh he was like a couple
years older than me but I knew him and
he uh
just jumped out of a 30-story building
and uh yeah just a ton of Coke
yeah you ever OD'd on coke
um not that I'm aware of what what's the
connection between the jumping out of
the 30-story window and the blow I asked
him if he's ever seen anybody else die
I didn't see him die I didn't see that
oh so two people jumped off of a
building yeah he's another dude who
jumped off a building that was just
connected yeah and 38 stories will do
the trip I'll do the trip for sure then
that the the the person in New York was
750 feet I think the the tallest
building in Downtown L.A is like 980
feet so that's a [__] tall ass
building I mean it's 10 foot per story
so 750 that's 75 stories
like do you think you're alive during
the whole fall like or do you think you
might have like a heart attack
I think and this might be a little bit
dark
that um it's it's
a really reasonably good way to go not
as good as a plane crash and I feel
strongly about this a plane crash is the
best way to go because right at the
moment that you realize the plane is
really going down like you know you know
you have long enough to deliberately
think your last thought
but not so long that you can more
between morbidly dwell on it or or you
know I feel like I'm not gonna have a
profound last thought though I feel like
I bet I'm like I bet I have some yeah
but then I'm like I'm like poop poop
they're just Splat yeah I feel like the
best way for me to go would be like I'm
in the mafia someone just comes at the
back of the head that's that's a good
one but it would have to be in over no
because then you like yourself like who
the [__] did this to me or I guess you
don't have time to think that yeah
you're like hey John but in Goodfellas
Pesci goes no you know he knows well
Pesci well yeah and then in Casino he
died by baseball beds I think that would
be the [__] that's a bad word yeah
she's had some bad deaths
yeah casino that ending of casino is as
dark as it gets just sum it up with a
metal baseball watching your brother
yeah yeah did you know Joe Pesci was
like a uh
yeah he's like a prolific singer
yeah there's albums it's so funny just
people have talents man like Showbiz
people it's so weird when you just see
an actor and you're like oh yeah I was
watching the new season of only murders
in the building and I'm like oh yeah of
course Meryl Streep can sing yeah that
would be [__] weird if she oh that
would be way funny or she just had like
a really bad voice and they're like
that's straight we got to keep it in you
know but have you ever heard like
Nicholson
we'll sing at the end of movies like uh
that movie did it's it's complicated not
it's complicated [__] what's it's with
Uh something's got to give with Diane
Keaton yeah and in the end he's singing
La Vie En Rose and the credits and
you're like he's kind of bad I think he
was singing in uh that Sandler movie too
um he kind of sounded good there were
they were like lawyers or something yeah
the same with like Clint Eastwood it's
like everyone wants to do other [__] at
the end of Gran Torino it's like this
cool ending and then you just hear
Eastwood singing you're like this guy
[__] sucks it's weird to make an
awesome movie and then you're just like
the hell is that [__] yeah that was
terrible
have you been in any movies appears
briefly I was in the Joker from yeah I
was a brief I I I played a stand-up
comic quite the [__] uh acting
tournament yeah no I played a comic and
uh it was a cool it was a cool role to
get to by the way a woman trolled me
once I did a bad joke on Twitter she
thought so she posted that clip of
Joaquin Phoenix I guess that means
you're like a hat because he's bad at
comedy and I'm like I'm literally in
that scene and this woman doesn't know
that that's like her thing of being like
you suck I'm like no I'm in that movie
yeah you know yeah yeah but uh yeah no
that was a fun experience like you know
Todd Phillips just like saw a stand-up
of me and Gary Goldman and he put us in
that movie and and uh Goldman's a great
comic and uh
and he was so [__] nice Todd Phillips
but I remember Gary shot right before me
so in the scene Gary isn't on stage uh
Joaquin Phoenix is in the crowd and it's
supposed to be the scene to be like he
doesn't get comedy because he's laughing
at the wrong parts of the joke but Gary
doesn't know that so there's some guy is
going like ah and Gary's like what the
[__] so Gary's like about to be like
[__] you dude and then finally notice it
like he was this close to taking
joaquin's head off and then being like
oh [__] that's Joaquin Phoenix this is
it's for the movie they didn't tell me
so I would be yeah on guard like what
the [__] but do you have any interest uh
any more interest in acting should I
make I'm not like that type of stuff is
super fun obviously I love movies so
sure but I'm not like you're not
pursuing I have no plans to be like you
know I'd really like to get deep in a
character no I I but I like I love
movies so I'm writing something I'm
gonna make myself like a web thing I'm
gonna make with my friend uh Gary
veteran and it's it's really funny it's
like uh it's gonna be out hopefully soon
I I will shoot it soon I mean
um it's hard for me to believe that a
movie as big as the Joker can get away
with shooting a scene and like it's like
the guy on stage in the scene doesn't
know that it's a scene well that's uh I
mean first off he's just a really good
actor you know Joaquin Phoenix like
you're like who the [__] is better than
that he's like as good as anybody right
yeah and then and then Todd Phillips
just knows he's so good he's a Todd
Phillips like a great combination of
like knowing comedy and then just
knowing how to make a good drama too but
uh I mean Tavo has made the best
comedies like the last 20 years old
school The Hangover road trip like all
great movies a road trip with Tom Green
it's a great movie dude no dude
that is road trip was such a better
movie than American Pie and America
First American Pie but road trip is
amazing yes American Pie one was good
the rest were okay and they came out
about the same time road trip was
phenomenal road trip in America it holds
up yeah we just watched it recently and
it really holds up it's a great movie
it's funny as [__] dude uh yeah oh I
guess [__] damn Stifler's in both
stiff was in both he yeah he got his she
was hot too that he got his prostate
[__] jerked off in there when they
went to the sperm clinic first time I
learned about that yeah
he's a little too young to be into that
though I feel like you got to be like at
least mid-20s to start taking a finger
in the butt because where do you go from
there yeah he was 18. yeah yeah I wonder
if Sean Williams Scott gets bummed on
being called Stifler like uh George
Casino it's like McLovin
it might be annoying because they
they've been in other good stuff they
want a good movie together Role Models
is great I thought role models are epic
it's really good Dude where's my car but
it's yeah dude he's been in so you're
right he's been in a lot of good stuff
that must that must be kind of annoying
but you know it also means you played an
iconic character isn't that what you
want as an actor you get you know did
you have any run-ins with uh Joaquin
Phoenix yeah we talked after I was gonna
talk to him because I I don't know about
acting really I'm kind of like I you
might be in your own thing you don't
want to deal with me maybe your full
method and he took it so seriously
clearly but I did like you know 15
different jokes maybe they kept me let
me just keep going it'd be like cut and
I had to get off stage when when like
all right Sam wrap up but as a comic you
know you get the light and you're like I
got like five minutes I'll figure it out
so one of the one of the takes he goes
Sam get off like yeah almost almost and
then and he's like Sam get the [__] off
my sorry sorry I just [__] up your
scene you know but uh because they're
like following Joaquin Phoenix and I'm
just in there but uh it was also
hilarious because Chris read you know
from SNL is the MC and uh and he just
his whole line is like one more time for
Samurai which there's no reason they
kept that in the movie except that Todd
is cool like there's no reason for him
to be like one more time for Sam Morrell
in the 80s you know that's it was just a
funny thing to do and then uh and then
he goes He introduces uh Joaquin Phoenix
so I'm gonna just do material and Chris
Red's like [__] you you get to like Flex
and have fun and I'm doing like one line
and sell it on Madison Square Garden
after that yeah Chris is really funny
though so I think he was just kind of
like annoyed but we were cracking up
about it and uh then so I just keep
changing the material and it's it's
going well like the extras who are
expecting me to suck and I'm like doing
my bits and it's getting big Pops in the
room because you know Todd Phillips is
like you're playing an open micro and I
was like so you want me to bomb or
something and he goes well just do your
jokes I'm not bombing in a [__] big
ass movie with my jokes dude I'm gonna
go up and kill so he's like that's fine
so every set every joke except one kill
one joke [__] ate it and I don't know
I think it was because it was an act out
but I think it's a funny bit but I think
it was too vulgar and Todd's like don't
do that joke again so I was like all
right so I just kept going but then at
the end of this at the end of The Run we
like pause in the middle and and Joaquin
Phoenix is just like standing there and
uh and Todd Phillips standing there and
and Joaquin was like I really like your
jokes and I was like oh that's [__]
cool and then Todd's like yeah he just
you know he just like sits in the room
and like the way you take actings here
so that's what he does with jokes and
joaquin's like it's really cool you know
I usually don't like love stand up but I
really like that's great and I really
liked this and I was like oh he's like
it's just it's not like needy it's just
funny and I was like oh cool man I was
like wow what a cool moment and then uh
you know and I didn't think they were I
didn't tell anyone I was in it because I
was like why are they even keeping me in
this movie it makes no sense but then
it's brought to my attention that the uh
you know all these people were tweeting
at me like Sam Morrell uh he's the
Joker's origin story because that's when
he descends into madness after he can't
follow Sam off on stage so that's like
the his you know most depraved so you're
responsible for all this I'm responsible
dude maybe Batman's parents would still
be alive if it wasn't for my [__]
awesome you know it's just crazy
was that taped at the seller Dangerfield
which is no longer here and it's so
weird because Rodney's like maybe my
favorite comedian ever like how do you
not [__] love Rodney danger I just
did Whitney's uh Whitney Cummings
podcast yesterday and uh I was telling
her how much I love Rodney and she goes
I'm making a movie about Rodney do you
want to and then she like called her
wife she goes I didn't really how much
you love Rodney and she's like do you
want to talk to his wife I was like [__]
yeah so I was just I'm literally doing a
Rodney impression on the phone uh for
Rodney's wife and she's laughing I'm
like how [__] weird is this well she
you know I'll tell you my mother never
breasted me she told me she liked me as
a friend you know and she gonna keep
another dress I don't know I'll tell you
I was an ugly kid my mother she liked to
breastfeed me through a straw I was that
ugly you know and she's like that's it
that's the joke and she was so freaking
cool and I'm like holy [__] I'm like
just like chatting with Rodney's and she
seems so sincere and so in love with him
still it's like very cool uh but uh yeah
[__] Rodney Dangerfield is it get any I
don't know if there's a funny or human
the amount you see his movies and every
character is just there to serve his
jokes like back to school his wife's
like oh you're impossible oh yeah and
you're easy you know
yeah
you're right I married you didn't I like
every joke is just like for I mean he
was the funniest dude ever so a buddy of
mine was his limo driver and he's like I
picked him up one time and we we drove
to Vegas and he's like listen kid get
there as fast as you can don't worry
about speeding I'll take care of
everything so he was hauling ass to
Vegas he got pulled over and and he he
rolled down the windows like send the
guy to the back and so the cop went to
the back and he's like all right you're
free to go wow of a ticket Chris what
are you gonna do give Rodney a ticket
that's what his wife said to me she goes
I'll tell you a Rodney joke that no
one's ever heard and I was like please
and she's told me this story that he had
brain surgery and they were like maybe
this is going to affect his speech and
he's not gonna make it and the first
thing that happens when he comes out is
you know of the surgery is they say you
know Ronnie did you cough anything up
and he goes yeah 500 weeks ago to a
[__] a 500 I [__] the joke up what do
you let me redo that did you cough
anything up yeah 500 bucks last week to
a [__] 27. oh my God that's funny I
believe the joke but yeah he's I mean
he's yeah he would just go on stage
wearing a robe and just his balls
hanging out
yeah that's what they say we're just
like his balls would always be out what
a weird he did he did uh he was like a
carpenter or did construction up until
50 years aluminum siding I think yeah he
gave up on Comedy then he came back at
50.
I mean that's that's it's so weird
wow man Legend
one of the funniest people of all time
yeah who was telling that story or like
he'd be walking through Vegas
and maybe it was Bert Kreischer was
talking about it where he'd used to be
walking with a bunch of guys and he'd be
like all right everybody come huddle up
huddle up and then he'd like take a rip
of weed and he's like all right break it
up break it up
he used to go to the comic strip
apparently which is like you know the
other club and he was like let's uh
let's do drugs here so I don't have to
do them at the Mi Club he was just like
popping in their Club thanks for coming
he's like no that's what I'm gonna do
drugs I'm not going to do them in my
club that'd be a bad look but uh yeah
dangerfields was like the coolest uh
Club in the 80s it looked like just like
all those great shows but when I by the
time I went there it was it was pretty
run down and dump and that's why I
worked well for that scene The Joker but
like man it was I never really worked
there I remember auditioning once and
every time I went up there I kind of ate
it it was kind of just not the best
comedy crowds but I killed the audition
and they still didn't pass me and and
the reasoning was fair she was just like
yeah you really did great but I just
don't think your humor will work here
and I was like Fair
you know oh that's that's just
auditioning to get spots at the club
yeah it was at a time where I just was
like I felt not comfortable enough at
any club and I was just even if I was in
at clubs I would be trying to get into
other clubs so like well maybe my spots
will dry up here and then I can go up
here but every club would just kind of
be hiding you for a minute and then cold
on you and uh thank God for the comedy
seller now they're pretty consistent but
uh yeah you know it's
it was always like you know I got to
stay fresh when I'm when I'm on the road
I'll do my long shows but in the city I
got a I gotta stay you know in shape
comedically yeah I was looking you up on
Wikipedia before we got here and I it
said you were born 86 87 question mark
86. can we for the record apparently a
lot of lies about me on Wikipedia from
what I've heard because someone told me
they say I'm 5 10 on there I'm like I'm
6'3 yeah I'm born 86 or 87 so for the
record and also did they say I'm from
um Massachusetts because I think they
say no they
you grew up in New York City okay there
you go yeah you are Ashkenazi yeah I'm
an Ashkenazi oh maybe they fixed it are
you 100 Ashkenazi
I mean a hundred I mean I think I'm like
80 something yeah I did the 23andMe
which I'm like uh you know cloning here
we come you look back at that decision
what a [__] bad idea all these
waivers we signed like I need to know
and then you get it you're like they're
gonna use this for evil yeah just
another [__] when the a that they're
gonna meet with the AI people and it's
going to come together and there's just
going to be a me at some funny bone and
like Toledo doing my ACT yeah but like
five dollars cheaper like when Tupac
comes out and raps on stage like it's
gonna be a comedians coming out on stage
I think so yeah
it's crazy man yeah man the uh the Deep
fake phenomena did that freak you out
well it hasn't started yet I mean
there's not been a like
serious thing that happened as a result
of deep faking it's gonna be amazing for
[__] with your friends and terrible
for elections yeah
I mean it'd be great to be like your
friends can be like I like to suck dick
and you send that to him but then like
for elections you can just have a guy
say anything and you're like oh [__]
this is ruining everything you know I
mean I gotta
I I sent to like uh like on on my our
little text thread like dude this is the
creepiest video ever and it was about
like where deep fake technology is right
now yeah the guy was like here's an
example of of uh you know a deep fake
and it was like some Kim Kardashian [__]
and then he says that was five years ago
here's one from now Jesus and like where
it is now is absolutely at plus the guy
himself as he's giving the whatever the
The Narrative you know in the video he
just turns into different people well
that's the creepy thing is like think
about you know just what cell phones
were 20 years ago yeah I remember like
having like a Nokia and you're like oh
my God snake yeah like that was
incredible this game is snake this is
great and now you're like oh yeah it
literally I can do anything with this
phone it's crazy yeah it's crazy because
there's women on Instagram with like
millions and millions of followers that
are like unbelievably gorgeous they're
AI and so you have these little kids
killing themselves because they
depressed because they don't look like
this but it's not even a real person and
they know it's [__] with kids
self-esteem though the weird thing about
like meta is like they'll do these tests
to be like is this damaging young
women's self-esteem and they're like
they'll be like oh overwhelmingly yes
you're like are you gonna change your
thing they're like no of course not
that's gonna get likes what are you
talking about yeah it's working for us
but it was crazy is like because I
didn't think anybody used Facebook
anymore but the meta stock is going
through the roof too yeah they're doing
all right and also uh you know I
remember like when phones had to
accomplished remember that early on
you're like oh cool this phone is a
compass now if you're Uber Eats guy is
not exactly yeah you know if you're
Uber's you're like what the [__] 40 feet
away you're like what are you a [__]
idiot you know yeah I mean look at the
meta stock I mean go for the last year
it tanked and then it went back up what
about that whole narrative the the
metaverse was a fail like no because
this is just getting started they're
working on other [__] too it's like the
VR I mean they're like versus his VR I
did a show for VR in Montreal they do
that it was like we just did crowd work
and it was for like they put the Oculus
this thing on your head you're like man
this is kind of cool but uh yeah I know
I did that and holy [__] I'm going on
first talk about like crowd work shows
for like where you have like if I do
crowd working at my show and I can like
weave it into jokes I'm smooth but when
it's like 20 minutes on the spot you
know I'm doing badly when they're like
do 15 and I'm like I've been up here
like 25 minutes they're letting me keep
going they're like find something here
but I [__] I was I slipped I called a
woman fat I'm like oh my God I'm [__]
bombing here this is terrible so you
were at home and you did it with to a
show in VR or how did that no it was
Montreal did you call a woman fat or did
you ask her if she was pregnant no no no
I just I wish I wish it was oh my God
that would have been that would have
been a savior no I just was like zinging
people one by one and that they all hit
and I got momentum at one point I'm like
with the zing zing and then I get to her
and I was like I did some planned words
about her being heavy and it was just
silence and I was like sorry I don't
know what do you say I mean I just have
to keep going so but how does the VR
work with them I don't know know I think
you just you had the Oculus headset and
you put it on and everyone's saying
Avatar but people are at home watching
you do comedy or with people in the
audience
um no they're at home no there are
people in the audience but they're not
in the headset no that would be [__]
ah that would be great that'd be like
crazy but no it's you watch it at home
and you and it's like they can like look
around they feel like you're you're
they're a part of the the show because
you're like in the round kind of you
know because people are doing that at
front row at the Lakers games like
you're at your house but your front row
and you're like looking at Lakers oh wow
yeah how you doing now doing that trip
during the pandemic they're doing it at
strip clubs they're gonna make and like
NBA players make so much this is gonna
go to them at some point like oh that
Scott that's crazy oh macaroni was
working on VR for for uh strip clubs
they got to make that but like a Knicks
game but yeah he was talking about it
yeah that's how I've they got they got
to make it for like the regular fan and
you pay extra but you get to sit next to
Tracy Morgan and hear his commentary I
sat behind him at a Nixon once it was
the funniest [__] I've ever like Tracy
Moore just not making any sense but it's
still kind of gold somehow we're like I
remember this nick uh Michael Beasley
had like the game of his life he was
just on fire and Tracy Morgan just turns
around to me and my friend he goes real
animals eat meat and we're like I don't
know what that means Tracy Morgan this
is [__] amazing yeah just all day
Tracy Morgan just going
it's like yeah dude I love it I saw him
one time leave the comedy seller and he
was just passing Louie like Louie's
going on Tracy just got off oh no no
Louie just got off and Tracy's going on
and uh and he goes you better left some
meat on that [__] for me and Louise
like I left a lot of meat on the [__]
for you
actually that's a good yeah he got in
the big car accident right with and he
got some money from Walmart really got
some money holy [__] I remember thinking
like because Artie Fuqua was in that too
and already like you know we know him at
the seller he hosts all the time I mean
he made so much money and I remember
immediately being like man I hope he
didn't blow it all on something stupid
he just rolls up immediately after I say
that in like a [__] tricked out
Rolls-Royce I'm like all right well
there goes that idea but uh but he made
so much he's fine you know and I mean
and people whoever think that like they
got overpaid or whatever she just like
he was in like a [__] coma it's awful
it's the the destruction that does to
your body I mean it was it a Walmart
payout like nobody's really upset oh
yeah exactly the villains the best line
about it I heard uh Chris Rock at the
seller one night he just said someone
said do you think Tracy would be okay
and Chris Rock goes it's not like
Tracy's comedy relied on precision
[Laughter]
yeah no Tracy Morgan's so funny dude
it's like and he's so like how do you
not love that guy there's old morning TV
clips of that guy just like taking his
shirt off
the segment like can you imagine you're
like you you host like good morning
Dallas or something and you should have
Tracy Morgan taking his shirt off and
then he's gonna impregnate the anchor
you're trying to keep this show like on
the rails and this dude's like this one
who pretends to be an amputee just like
puts his foot back and he's like I was
wounded in Vietnam and they're like I
don't know what to do with this but
that's the genius he's just making it
you know
uncomfortable I love I love [__] with
morning TV people because it's like
literally the only way you're gonna sell
tickets like no one no one if I behave
No One's Gonna give a [__] but if I just
do something horrible it's gonna be
hilarious I was watching some of your
morning TV interviews this today and it
they look so awkward yeah it's
uncomfortable when you're in studio
because they do not like me yeah but
it's way fun yeah I remember the one
that really it's hilarious yeah the one
they really got mad at was good morning
Pittsburgh I know pitch no comic who
ever played the Pittsburgh improv after
me uh has done that show since I ruined
it for everybody but uh it was a oh
there it is yeah that's the top one oh
yeah that one 21 seconds yeah that one
right there yeah they were not happy
how long ago was this years ago
but they just asked me enough bad
questions and I was just bored and on
two hours of sleep and I you know and
you know you just are like what can I do
to make this uh is that it yeah that
might no that's not that's another one
that's Kentucky
that one's Pittsburgh
Isaac is not having his best day running
the the most yeah put the sound on too
oh man do we not get Wi-Fi in here maybe
so they asked you have you always been
and how many times you gotten this
question you're just like do a little
ask me something original
fight would be on charge thanks but no
you know it's funny when I was young I
was molested by an uncle and that gave
me super powers pretty funny
story you know okay because this is
awesome
yeah they were not happy I remember I
was leaving and they were I was like hey
can I get a cut of that uh that video
and they go get out
and they were so mad yeah I just tweeted
I was like did anyone watch that and
someone was like I taped it I was like
all right thank God but uh no so many of
them
like what do you want me to do with
those questions I have to do something
you know
it's like somebody coming up to you and
it's like okay funny guy tell me a joke
basically yeah so yeah they were not and
the live one the problem is I only want
to do the live ones because if I'm funny
in like any others in their tape they're
just gonna cut out anything funny I say
I've definitely done those where it's
like a 20 minute interview and then I
see it on TV and I'm like 30 seconds
come on what the hell so uh but but then
my Publishers will text me she's like I
can't just ask for live interviews they
know you're [__] with them I was like
all right fair enough but uh yeah we did
one on uh good morning Raleigh or
something and holy [__] was a guy mad at
us because we were just uh
it was live TV and they're just so
Southern and proper and uh we're on the
tour bus and I pretended to be uh
healthy I'm like we're on a health kick
we're all eating salads and I turned
around my friend Gary's blowing lines
and uh it's fake lines but on TV they
were Furious and uh they cut the segment
on the spot and uh yeah I don't know if
that we have that no oh those people are
awesome actually those it's funny the
good interviewers are the ones that got
freaking fired those people that were
[__] on the Chicago show Good Morning
America ah
no this isn't a good interview because I
mean this is actually just a good
interview they do because they actually
were great at their jobs but uh but they
got fired for he was banging everybody
there I think that black guy with those
pretty green eyes you know that guy I'm
talking about yeah I remember it I'm
trying to think exactly because I was on
there and I can't remember if it was
before or after but he was being in well
they were hooking up and I think they're
still together but she was uh they were
both like good interviewers they were
very talented
um and you could just tell when you're
on a good show versus a bad show but
when you're a good show I just want to
give a good interview now you know yeah
but uh but uh no so many of the small
town ones they're just like they don't
care about you they're just like bored
by you so I'm like well I'm gonna make
this terrible yeah I remember we went to
one at like 5 30 in the morning six in
the morning and like the guy was just so
[__] loud and in your ear and it was
just like he it was so annoying and some
of these like morning radio guys just
try like they're trying to be yet and
they're just so [__] like caffeine
pilled out and like you'd be like Danny
bonaducci screaming at you in your ear
it's like Jesus dude like it's too early
for this [__] you know some of them
where they're just like they ask you
questions I'm like you don't you did no
research and like it's fine you don't
have to but like but don't expect me to
like bring my a game like yeah where
they yeah I did one recently I used to
do a podcast with the football player
Julian Edelman he's the man I love him
but like the questions they were asking
me about them were like uh they were
like so you know that picture uh where
Julian woke up after the Super Bowl that
some woman took at him who she just had
sex with him and I was like yeah and she
goes were you there too and I was like
no it was the woman like what do you
want me to do with that [__] that's like
that's your setup for me yeah no he
[__] a fan or something I don't know
you know yeah it's probably why podcasts
are blowing up because it's like
you know well this [__] yeah I mean this
thing is like like we're having a real
conversation it's like you know you
we're in a [__] van dude yeah we are
in a creepy van dude well it's nice to
be in a van that's not creepy I mean
it's like you know there's air
conditioning there's liquid deaths
yeah this is if the Zodiac Killer was
still alive this is where he would do a
podcast
[__] yeah no this is cool this is and uh
and you guys are like blowing up it's
big that's good yeah thank you for
saying that we put on a good run dude
we're super stoked
um I think uh I'm trying to figure out
which is the more
um
age-restricted podcast you are or Mark
I would say Mark yeah oh my God yeah
yeah art goes hard I mean that's kind of
I feel like I've turned into like the
straight man on our podcast because Mark
will just like fart on a guest and I'm
like well I can't go further than that
you know so I just have to be like Mark
you know but uh no we have I love
hanging with Mark I mean we've been
friends for so long so it's uh he's
fantastic but both of you guys are
fantastic yeah you guys are awesome I
loved I loved doing uh your pocket I
feel like I I was telling stories on
your we might be drunk podcast that
about my like the history with my
checkered sexual past and my fiance was
present that was crazy hearing some of
this stuff like the the really dark
stuff that she's never heard I think so
yeah she must trust the [__] out of you
though because you were so honest I mean
it's like it's nice you know
and uh it and things happen to the fact
I thought she was hearing it for the
first time and I think after the
pictures I go no I already knew that
stuff yeah but the fact that you thought
it was the first time it shows how
honest you are is there anything that
comes up now where she's like I didn't
know that I think we've got pretty much
all the the rats have scurried out of
the club
[Applause]
um
slept for Madison Square Garden yeah I'm
gonna be everywhere I'm gonna we got
Bethlehem Pennsylvania York Toronto
that's a big theater Chicago uh the
Meridian Hall I think Chicago Theater in
Chicago is a big one gonna be in Phoenix
Pittsburgh Cleveland Columbus Cincinnati
Indy uh the the the Theater Madison
Square Garden and then I'm heading all
over Australia Brisbane Melbourne yeah
you gotta say Brisbane Brisbane sorry
Vegas we're the second time this year
I'm going to Vegas I'm trying to win
instead of the Mirage this time just
mixing it up they didn't have room but
then Tampa and then my least favorite
city in the country Naples Florida I'll
be returning to I [__] hate those
people so it's a Revenge gig shame on
all the [__] vapid Rich pieces of
[__] in Naples I will I will strike down
with great Vengeance yeah uh that show
will be crazy uh I wish I wish death on
a guy last time I was there and I'll
[__] do it again yeah because he said
he said you mumbled yeah that was one
yeah that was another one that's how you
promote a show I think we just sold out
Naples Naples dude we have a lot of fans
in uh in Australia too so yeah we just
got back from uh how many 54 cities in
90 days in Australia I think it was 54
shows in 42 cities 42 cities yeah and
like even Australians have no idea that
there's 42 cities yes yeah you said that
I was like I did not think we went up
big everybody thinks there's like seven
we went on the most extensive Australia
tours I've never been dude ah man you're
gonna love it you're gonna love it where
are you going in Melbourne where are you
playing I don't remember I think you
gotta say Melbourne Melbourne Melbourne
I don't know man yeah dude I had my
biggest show on my website they just
showed my entire life in Melbourne
um like uh
yeah we did 4 500. we did the podcast
with Cheeto Santino there oh [__] could
do we shouldn't have moved here yeah
here's a shooting movie he's a great
actor yeah I just saw him on uh what's
that one uh with uh Dave no the the it
was on Netflix uh it was like an Asian
show
he was uh no it was a big with the
female comedian why am I [__] beef
beef he was on beef he was one of those
[__] yeah that was a really good I heard
it's great that was a great TV show The
Place theater never heard of it but I'll
yeah I'll be there in Australia yeah
yeah dude you're gonna love Australia
MSG got uh four comedy specials out
there I got I got five I think I got
well I have a half hour on Comedy
Central that's with an album but then uh
yeah I got a special on YouTube called
positive influence I got I got this
which may be my best one and then uh up
on the roof and and uh the new Netflix
one and I'm gonna tape a new one in in
Boston in March so I'm pumped for that
when you did the Netflix one with did
you license it to them yeah so you get
the rights back after two years yeah
that's cool yeah so that was I think
that's good I think you know people are
so but you know YouTube worries me now
too where I think uh you know my friend
Joe let's just put one out and it's
killer and he uh he said that they got
demonetized because he said the the word
in the special so it got demonetized and
uh you know uh yeah he gets killed in
the algorithm and like we were going up
as comedians as against a robot that
can't detect sarcasm or doesn't
understand comedy and and it's not like
a person being like Oh that was ironic
with this you know so uh that's
dangerous and I think YouTube was safer
but they keep moving that goal posting
and I'm I am worried about the future of
Comedy I really am yeah I I I I can't
um put my uh
my jacking off footage on YouTube yeah
that's the real problem yeah that but no
yeah you're gonna it's crazy because I
probably have to put that on PornHub
yeah only fans PornHub it's bad that's
about it yeah
but yeah man dude I'm super stoked it's
uh it's a pleasure to get you on here
man yeah we love having you on ours too
yeah fun to be here when uh did you go
out
all right so you're here for uh where
were you in L.A I'm just doing the
region tonight I uh maybe I'll do a
little tap dance for the industry we'll
see if anyone wants to buy my new
special and uh I was here a couple
months ago so I was just I didn't really
it's funny I now I kind of wish I had
him come out to that show because it was
a bigger venue but uh okay it's probably
better now the jokes are probably a
little better the the Calgary one I'm
guessing that uh The Great Outdoors Fest
oh [__] which by the way
wildfires everywhere uh I just did
Edmonton and I'm there with uh
Theo Von and
dude the [__] City
it's like the smokiest air you've ever
taken in I was like man this air quality
sucks and Theo's like nah man it's cool
and then cut to 30 minutes later our
agent called us so like the province has
shut down the city the Show is canceled
we flew in a night early because we're
like we gotta get there a night early
there's no direct flights to Edmonton
yeah New York or L.A and uh you know so
like [__] it I guess the show's canceled
I'm not just gonna take their money so
they're like will you stay another night
and I was like yeah we'll stay another
night would the arrow get better they're
like yeah the air is 10 times worse the
quality is brutal the show is on we're
like you know do this by the way you
can't do a [__] show indoors for two
years because of covet now we're doing
we can't perform Outdoors like wow this
is getting dark you know and then we do
the gig it's great but uh you know
and then I'm flying back with the
connect through Montreal and the because
of the [__] air I got stuck in
Montreal also there's like a four night
although there's worse there's worse
places to be stuck Montreal is insidiful
yeah dude all right all right man one
dude kill it at the region and uh
[__] kill it at MSG and actually kill
those people in Naples I'm gonna I'm
gonna no God is gonna do that for me
they're on death the door already they
got I'm taking this is literally like
the end it's the end of the road that's
what I said last time he heckled me some
guy heckled me and uh I said [__] I
can't wait to leave here and he goes
yeah well you're still here and I said
yeah I'll be gone in the morning and
you'll be dead soon and he and he goes
you'll have to put me in the ground it's
like I was like no that's not how time
works and I was like all right thank you
very much that was like my show thank
you very much I wish death on 47 people
I've been Samurai and they were like
yeah [__] hated me like the Joker up
there I really was Joaquin had a better
set in that movie than I had in Florida
pleasure to meet you
is that dude awesome enough I mean come
on I love him and check out how awesome
we are because as this comes out it's
tomorrow that his tour starts that
Madison Square Gardens theater that's
November 4th it's now is the time to
jump on this guy's tour and it's also
the time for me to thank you the
wonderful
street team and I'm super stoked because
I'm finally developing a special wild
ride street team t-shirt and I was just
gonna make it be like uh the Wild Ride
logo with some cool maybe like graffiti
thing because that's like a street team
kind of thing and after the Wild Ride
logo and then have it be like spray
painted street team underneath it
and uh and Lux she says
make it Doper than that so we're taking
our time and really trying to figure out
what's going to be the dopest wild ride
street team shirt and uh
I like to think I'm never ever gonna
promote it anywhere but it's a Tippy
tail end of the Wild Ride podcast
because it's the only [__] time I
talk to my beautiful wonderful beloved
street team
so you guys are it I loved you and I
want you to have the best day ever thank
you
okay
[Music]